אנחנו מה הקטע של הקה יכול להסביר לי איך
אני משחק על המצלמות אה אכלתם את הראש אתם
כן אתה יודע כמה שעסקים בעריכה אנחנו א
בונים את הביטחון שלנו על בסיס אלחים
כחטיבה כגדוד ההצלחה שלנו בהלחים קודם כל
אנחנו כל הזמן מקפידים להגיד לעצמנו
בצניעות ולא להרים את הראש ולא לעוף על
עצמנו אבל זה מאוד משמעותי ללוכם ולפקד
אדם אחת יש לנו ביטחון במה שעשינו בקרב
הראשון שלנו מול חזבל בלבן ככה אנחנו באים
לבנצ'בל בנועל קרב הכנות
ולוקחים הרבה מהרכיבים של מה שעבד לנו טוב
לצורך העניין קרב ההתקדמות הלילי ההגעה
ברצף של מספר גדודים אנחנו לוקחים את
המאפיינים האלה מלבישים אותם גם על
בינצ'בל ויוצאים לדרך עוברים דרך חתיבה ד
שנה שיצא להתקפה לילה קודם ותפסה את
הפעתים של היתרון
ומשם אנחנו בעצם בקרב התקדמות לילי הגדוד
בציר אחד הסיירת בציר שני ואנחנו אמורים
להיות מתואמים בכניסה
10 בלילה שסיירת כבר חצו גדר נכנסים ואני
רואה שמתקדמים באייקונים במשואה בקצב מהיר
מאוד והנתיב תנועה שלנו היה בתוך הנחל דרך
היתרון מאוד בוציא והקרקעשה מאוד התגרה את
הגם את הרקם את כל הכלים
צריך גם להגיד פה משהו להוסיף
שיול הפיע הרבה מאוד ביטחון בנועל קרב
אני עובר את זהמחת אני אתה לא נהנים לי
לפרק אותו עכשיו אבל אני אומר בסוף
אני לא היקב בו
אני אומר הוא הביא הרבה ביטחון היה שמה
שינוי הבנת המציאות זה שינוי
כן כן
או בשתי מילים כאילו
זה כמובן החיכוך הראשוני עם הקרקע בלילה
הזה מביא אותנו בתחילת הקרב לכמה שינויים
ממה שתכננו
הגדוד 52 תכנן להיכנס מציר שהוא ניתח
ובסוף אבין שזאת לא הדרך הנכונה ולהגיע
דרך הציר שהסיירת פותחים אה ובעצם בעצם
אדו שקד אנחנו בהתקדמות מתחכים עם הקרקע
ופשוט נתקעים יש לי דחפור שנתקע ונוטה על
צידו כמעט מתהפך יש לי א פנדה דחפור שהוא
לא מעווי שגם נתקע א ביצת זהב שסוחבת 5000
ליטר סולר שגם עוד שנייה נופלת מהדחפור
אנחנו בעצם פה עוצרים והזמן עובר
מחט שואל אותי לוריה מה קורה עם ההתקדמות
שלכם? הוא רואה גם את הפער שנפתח בין הקרב
של הסיירת לקרב שלי. א ואני בשלב הזה אומר
לו עוד 10 דקות, עוד 20 דקות אנחנו מנסים
לחלץ את הכלים ואני מנסה לקבל החלטה מה
הכי נכון לי לעשות בשלב הזה. לי ברור
שהעמידה במשימה זה בראש ובראשונה. אין מצב
שאני לא מיוצב בח בבוקר על עין אתה איפה
שקבענו בנו על קרב הסערת לא מתייצבת שם
לבד זה לא יכול לעבוד אם זה קורה הוא חוטף
מהצד הוא חוטף מאיפה שאני אמור לתקוף בעין
זה חיי אדם וזה לעמוד בשין וזה הזמנים
שקבענו ואני תקוע בתוך היתרון
ואיפושהו ב4 לפנות בוקר הזמן כבר דוחק
ואני מקבל החלטה
להשאיר את הכלים בשטח ולהשאיר את הסמגד
ולהגיד לו שמגד המאמץ של כל הכלים שתקועים
בהצלחה אני לא מתעסק בזה שלך אני רץ
למשימה
ואנחנו יוצאים עם א ממפי השריון ממפי
רובעית ממפי אחות ויוצאים לתקוף את הפעתים
של עינתא ועומדים בשן 5 בבוקר גדוד שקד
נמצא בעין ביחד ומקביל לסייר
ומפרקים שם את מערב אדיפוס ממש על ציר
אדיפוס א מתייצבים אור ראשון סורקים את
האיתורים מתארים את המרחב
ולסיירת היו התקלויות בלילה בציר תנועה
שלהם ואני חושב שמהעוצמה הזאת שהם הגיעו
במהירות שלהם גרם לאויב לנטוש את העמדות
שלו כי כשאנחנו הגענו לציר אדיפוס ולמערב
עצמו לא פגשנו אויב
פגשנו את הרכיבים של המערב מטעני
בתים עם הרבה עמלה.
זה בעצם הלילה הראשון.
תשמע,
קודם כל משיח קליפ צבעים לדעתי עם הכמות
כלים שהיה
זה אחד שתיים א בוא נדבר שנייה על מערב
עידן אביב על תאיר מערב עידן אביו. אחרי
זה אני רוצה אותך לחמש דקות על האירוע
שהיינו שם שציל. איך קראו אגב? לא קראו
לזה ש
אה
במהלך הקרבות שם בעינתן אני מבין ואני
משתף גם את המחת שיש מרחב שאם אני מתפתח
אליו זה מרחב בתי הספר על ציר עידן אם אני
מתפתח אליו זה מייצר לחטיבה איזשהו מפרק
שדרכו החטיבה תוכל להתפתח לרכס המחיצה
ובניתוח הזה אני בסוף מאשר מול המחת
שהגדוד עוזב את המגנן בעין ויוצא להתקפה
על המרחב הזה שקראנו לו המפרק האופרטיבי א
ציר עידן
ו
בפירוק של המערב הזה והמרחב הזה אנחנו
מגלים כמה סימנים מכשידים
מעיקונים שעולים לנו א באמצעים המיוחדים
של השריון אה ודרך אה א זיהויים של תנועות
במרחב הזה. אני מבין שכנראה יש שמה ארכות
אויב. צריך להגיד זה גם זו נקודה אסטרטגית
כי יושבת בגובה ששולטת גם על צירי הכניסה
מהארץ מהיתרון וגם על הירידות ממרון הרס
צירי יצר.
ואם אני מבין שהאויב נערך שם, כנראה יש שם
הרבה רכיבים ואולי גם אויב שעדיין נמצא
שם. ובהתקפה שלנו על המרחב הזה עדרי הממפה
של הרובית מרים רחפן ומזהה אחד הממים שלו
בעצם עם הרחפן ומזהה מצלמת פז ענקית
שמכוונת לכיוון ציר.
זה מצלמה של האויב. אחד אני מופטע שיש להם
את האמלך הזה והשימוש ככה בpzז
מרחוק א אבל הופה אנחנו מבינים שיש פה
משהו מטעדים את זה סורקים את הבניין
מוציאים את הPTZ אני מסתכל בכשית של הPTZ
לראות רגע מאיפה היא על מה היא מסתכלת מה
שטח ההשמדה של אותה מצלמה
א
אבל אני לא מבין את כל הסיפור בשלב הזה
אנחנו ממשיכים את הסריקות של המתחן
של אד מבתי הספר שמה באזור ואנחנו מסיימים
לסרוק את הבית ספר אני רואה בזווית של
העין מכונית שנראית לי חשובה מתחת לסכחה
אני בעצם מתקרב למכונית הזו אני רואה
במרחק לא גדול שבתוך המכונית יש חביות
כחולות
זה ישר מקפיץ אצלי את ההבנה שזה כנראה רכב
ממול מולקד צועקים רכם במולקד לקחת את
כולם אחורה מעיפים את כולם אחורה לוקחים
טווח בטיחות מטיסים לשם רחפן אבותר מה
שהרחפן מזהה הוא פשוט מטורף חביות כחולות
משורשרות עם חומר נפץ וכמות של חומר נפץ
זה נראה כמו
החומר נפץ שאנחנו שמים לפיצוץ של מבנים
ואני מבין שהולך להיות פה פיצוץ עוצמתי
אני מחזיר את כולם לבתים בהגנה מבין V
טנק. הממפי בעצם מגיע בטנק. ממפי השריון
יורף פגז לתוך הרכב ו הכל שם מתפוצץ,
מקריס את הבית ספר, בטח את הסכחה, הרכב
מתעדה, חלקים מהרכב עפים לכל כיוון ו
נס גדול. נס זה גם מקצועיות בסוף הזיהוי
והבנה של כל הרכיבים
אבל המחבלים תכננו ושמו לנו רכב טופת על
מרחב שבאנו לסרוק אותו והבנו שזה שטח שהוא
שטח מפתח
צריך גם להוסיף פיטרו אותם היה שמה המון
המלך
כן
המון נשקים המון רובי צי כאלה
די פיטרו אותם שמה עבדות עם זה
כן כן
בוא נדבר על ההתעגלות שבעצם הבחו שם ספר
את האירוע הזה
אז א המשכנו בבנצ'בל בתיאור המרחב והתחלנו
להתקדם לכיוון הקסבה של בינג'ביל עכשיו
כדי להגיע לקסבה של בינ'בל אתה לא חוצה
ועובר את כל השטח שיש בינך לבין הכסבה
צריך לטאר אותו אתה לא רוצה שיצא לך
מחבלים בעורף אחרי שאתה נמצא בתוך הקסבה
ויתקעו אותך מאחורה ולכן באופן שיטתי
פלוגה סורק את ציר אחד שיורד לכיוון הקסבה
פלוגה סורקת סיר שני שיורד לכיוון הקסבה
את שני האיתורים מצדדי הראשון א ובאופן
שיטתי ככה אנחנו מתקדמים המחת מגיע אליי
לביקור אנחנו יושבים עם הפלוגה הרופאית עם
אדרי ממפי באחד האיתורים שהוא כבר סיים
לכבוש
נהלים איזה שיחה קצרה ואני מקבל דיווח של
התקלות בסטריפ השני בצד השני איפה שממפה
יכול שפירה
סליחה צ'ליק זה חייב
אז אני מקבל דיווח על התקלות איפה שמפח
בסטריפ השני איפה שממפה החוד צ'ליק נמצא
א ממפי חדש שנכנס לתפקיד שבועיים קודם לכן
זה הקרב הראשון שלו ההתקלות הראשונה שלו
בתפקיד ואני מבין שהמיקום שלי לא צריך
להיות פה צריך להיות אצלו אני יוצא
מהעיתור אני מדווח למחת פנים פנים אני
אומר לו יש לנו התקלות שם שם אני יוצא עם
החפק
אני רוצה רגע שנייה לעצור עוד פעם
היית היית קצת לחוץ אני מכיר אותך גם מאצל
מתלווה לאייזר לפעמים וזהכן
זה הג שהוא היה אירוע ראשון
אה אחד הלחץ
זה אירוע ראשון קודם כל אני לא נמצא שם
אני נמצא
במקביל עם ממפי שהוא יותר מנוסא והמפי
צ'ליק שרק נכנס לתפקיד בהתקלות הראשונה
שלו זה מעלה לי את סף הלחץ
לרמה מאוד גבוהה. אני צריך להגיע כמה
שיותר מהר לצ'ליק, להיות איתו, לראות שהוא
עושה את הדברים בצורה נכונה ובסוף גם
בתוצאה מה יש פה התקלות. אני מבין גם שיש
פצועים תוך כדי.
אוקיי, אני מבין אותך שתיה למשהו מסוים.
אתה מגיע לשם,
תאונת המצב שדיוחת בקשת היא לא תחת המצב
שאתה מגלה אותה במחום.
כן.
ספר את זה.
זה אני מבצע ריצה דילוג מאוד מהיר אחת
נמצא ביחד איתי בריצה הזאת אנחנו מגיעים
למרחב של ההתקלות של צ'יק צ'ליק רץ אליי
אומר לי מגד הכל בשליטה אנחנו בהתקלות על
הפתח
וממשיכים לנהל אש אני בתמונת המצב מבין
אוקיי יש מחבלים בתוך האיתור מנהלים אש על
האיתור עצמו ויש פצוע
בתוך מתוך זה אני מבין שהממם
נכנס לאיתור בכניסה מחבלים פתחו עליו שני
מחבלים ירו עליו הוא נפצע חטף כדור בקרמי
דרך העולם וכדור באגודל שפשוט העיפה לו את
האגודל
וצ'ליק היה איתו בחוליית החוד הממפה נמצא
שם איתו
ובשלב של הפינוי של הממ מהפתח היה שמה
מרווח של איזה דקה שלא נהלו אש עם הפתח
עצמו.
ואת זה לא הבנתי בדיווח הראשוני, את זה
הבנתי בדיעבד אחרי שתחקרנו את האירוע
בשטח. אבל בשלב הזה אני מבין ונותן גם
לממפי פקודות בוא נוציא את כולם לאור ליד
נביא טנקים נתחיל לפרק את האידור הזה
פגזים מקלים
וברגע שנכניס אחרי המכת הזאת רחפן אולי
נעתר את המחבלים בפנים זה מה שאנחנו עושים
מביא את הטנקים מחלקת חיר מתייצבת על
האיטור ליד סורקים הם רחפן אני לא מוציא
מחבלים בפנים. אין שום דבר בתוך האיתור.
היא תופסת צ'יק. צ'ליק איפה המחבלים? אמרת
שהם בפנים. ניעלתם מתמש בעיתור עצמו.
הוא לא יודע לענות אבל אנחנו עוצרים את
המכתש ונכנסים לסריקה רגלית בהיתור עצמו.
אני ביחד עם המפי נכנסים בקומה שממנו ירו
על הממם ואין מחבלים. מה כן יש? תיקים של
מערכות הפעלה של מטענים,
תיקים של אוכל של מנקים של מחבלים. אנחנו
מבינים שכן היו שם מחבלים וקצת מפשפשים
בקרקע. גם אני רואה את התרמילים של
הקלאץ'. אז זה שהיו שם מחבלים זה בוודאות.
שניים גם מצאנו שני טלפונים שלהם מסלקים
בתוך מקרר.
ופה נופל לי הסימון. הם הצליחו לברוח בשלב
הזה שהם פינו את המפתח.
השלב הזה שפינו אותו אחורה ולא היה אש עם
המחבלים בפנים לא ניעלו את המגע הזה.
מרווחצר המחבלים הצליחו לברוח מדלת אחורית
להמשך
ה פוליגונחת שומע את זה בקשר אני הייתי
שמה עם ציימנו את זה אומר עדמא בואו שנו
בריצה לשם הוא מגיע אליך מספר את זה תגיד
תתחיל את השיחה מה שאתה רש מחליט ברגע זה
הוא מצטרף אליי אנחנו בעצם מייצרים תתנת
מצב
ומפסקים זה חשוב במילים האלה מפסקים את
מרחב הניתוח שלנו את מרחב היום
זה כי שיטת עבודה שעשיתם
שלאט לאט נגסתם זה מה שפתרת היום
אני אגיע אה
שעה 23 דקות אני רוצה רק שזה
כן
תחושת כישלון
הכי עמוקה שיכולה להיות לא יכול להיות
שמחבלי חזבלה בורחים לגדוד שקד אנחנו
בהתעקלות איתם ומצליחים לברוח זו לא תוצאה
של גדוד שקד זו לא תוצאה של גיב
ואני יושב שמה אחד איך אנחנו מצליחים
להביא אותם ולחסל אותם
ובודקים את השטח שהם ברחו מהור ומנסים
להתחכות אחריהם אני מבין שהם נכנסו למקבץ
איתורים זה יכול להיות ארבעה יתורים שהם
נכנסו אליהם בלי שנראה אותם בורחים מס
ואני אומר לעצמי אם אני עכשיו ברגע זה
נכנס עם הכוח הזה לתוך הארבעת היתורים
האלה אני בעוד עוד התקלות פנים מבנים. מה
אני עושה בזה? זו לא הדרך. ואני מחליט
לבחור פה בשיטת פעולה של בידוד ארבעת
האיטורים האלה, הכנת הכוח שהוא מוגבר יותר
עם שני צקפים, שתי פלוגות.
ובעצם כל הלילה אנחנו מבודדים את ארבעת
האיתורים האלה. חיספנו שטח עם דיניים,
אחזנו עם רחפן, שמנו כלים, טנקים שיודעים
להתר יציאה מתוך האור הזה וכמובן יורים על
המרחב כדי לוודא שהמחבלים נשארים בתוך
האיתורים ומרגישים מאוימים מלצאת.
עובר הלילה בתצורה הזו ובבוקר שאחרי אני
שולח את ממפה הרובאית עם באגר ממוגל
להתחיל לקלף את ארבעת האיתורים האלה כדי
שהעיתור יהיה מקולף ונחסוף את המחבלים
שנמצאים בפנים זה בטח ייצור תחושת נרדפות
גם אצל אותם מחבלים
בממפח עוד יוצא 8:00 בבוקר מתחיל קילוף של
האיתור הראשון קילוף של האיתור השני
המחבלים עושים את הטעות של החיים שלהם תה
להם בחיים בסוף הם הם יורים על הבגר
הממוג, מטומטמים עם קלאץ', זה לא עושה
כלום כמובן, אבל זה חוסף אותם מפה שורשרת
הדיווחים, הממפי אומר, התקלות מזהה את
המחבלים פותח עליהם באש והמחבלים האלה
מתחילים לרוץ בין ארבעת האיתורים ועושים
לנו ממש רנדלים. ורק להבין לאיזה איתור הם
נכנסו, הגיעו איזה שישה שבעה רחפנים
מכוחות שונים כדי לתת לי תמונת מצב. איפה
המחבלים עכשיו? הם כל רגע עוברים ואנחנו
לא מצליחים להרוג אותם מנגד.
אה, בשלב הזה הם נכנסים לתוך איתור אחד.
אני מבין שהם בתוך האיתור הזה. אנחנו
מצמים את כל הכוחות אל מול איתור אחד.
וככה אני מבודד ומבין יש פה שני מחבלים
בתוך עיתור אחד. וכאן יש גם הכוונה של
מזכב
שנותן שני קרדומים לתוך האור
ועוד טנק שנותן שבעה שמונה פגזים. וככה
אנחנו בעצם שסיימים את האירוע שהבאגר
הממוגן מגיע לאיתור עצמו כדי לנסות ולקלף
אותו. הוא מקריס את האיתור דווקומתי. הוא
מקריס את האיתור על המחבלים.
משהו אחד לא הבנתי בתורך הדבר הזה. אמרת
שעבר לילה. כן, עבר לילה בין ההתקלות
הראשונה לבין ההתעקלות ה
הלות הראשונה גם שתמחברים.
זה אותם שני המחבלים שברחו לצ'ליק וסגרנו
על המעגל ביום שאחור.
אז המחת החליט להגיע בהתקלות השנייה.
לא, בהתעקלות הוא היה איתי גם בראשונה וגם
בשנייה. אולי אתה לא היית בראשונה.
אני באותו יום אני קיבלתי גם אני צילמתי
את את הבגר את
זה השנייה
זה הלילה שאחר.
כן. אז אה
זאת אומרת עבר יום אחד
לילה
לילה אחד
לילה שאנחנו בבידוד המרחב. לא רציתי
להיכנס לשטח חשמדה בלילה לא מאורגם.
ואם היינו עושים את זה היינו חוטפים עוד
פצועים כמו שהממם שלי נפצ
א
בעצם בשלב הזה
הבית מוקרס על המחבלים אבל אני לא יודע
בוודאות שהמחבלים נמצאים שם כי לא ראיתי
גופות ולא ככה מסיימים אירוע מסיימים
אירוע שיש לך גופות אוזניים ביד זה לא
עובד ככה
ואנחנו מביאים את הבאגר הממוגן כדי להתחיל
לקלף את העריסות שהוא יצר בעצם עד שנמצא
את הגופות בסוף סוף אחרי שעה מוציאים את
שתי הגופות של המחבלים עם וסטים, עם נשקים
ומבינים שזה הבינגו, המחבלים שברחו
לילה לפני,
סגרנו את המעגל יום אחרי וזו תוצאה של
גדוד שקט וחטיבת גיב משהו אחר
יפה מאוד תשמע לפני שאתה מסיים יש לו משהו
שאתה רוצה לספר מבחינת הוייב שמה יש משהו
אחד שאני אם יש ליך עוד חמש דקות אני
הרגשתי המון המון ביטחון ששמעת בך זאת
אומרת נוצר מצב בבינגבש יוצר פיסוק מטורף
כן
והוא נתן לך את המרחב המפוסק ואמר תשמע נו
אני אומר לך כאילו מה אני ראיתי כן
כן
לא יסגור לי את הפינה הזאתי אני סומך עליו
שירוץ עם הסיפור הזה
אתה מקבל את הפיסוק הזה מה אתה אומר לעצמך
מניות לדעת אתה מבין הוא היה פיסוק רציני
אה
התייחסת לזה לא התייחסת לזה אתה
אז אני כמובן משקף למחת אם אני מרגיש לא
בנוח עם משהו מבצע זאי אמחת לא הייתה
ברירה
כן אבל בסיטואציה הזו הרגשתי מאוד בנוח
הגדוד גדוד מלסה גדוד מקצועי מאוד עצמאי
מאוד והפגשתי מאוד בנוח לפעול במרחק א
מהחטיבה על כל המשמעויות של זה א ואני
חושב שהמקום הזה של א גדוד שנותן לחתיבה
את התחושה הזאת של הביטחון של אפשר לסמוך
אפשר להיות להיות עצמאי בלחימה מאוד חשוב
זה חיב חשוב בסוף את לא יכול להיות כל
היום צפוף וזה תחושה נראה לי מאוד מורכבת
למחת לפקד על לחימה שגדוד פה וגדוד שם
וגדוד באמצע והוא הוא כל פעם יכול להיות
בסוף במקום אחד והלשחרר והעצמאות הזאתי זה
נבנה זה נבנה והתקופת לחימה שלנו בלבנון
ביחד בנתה את זה מלחיה ועוד לפני מהתרגל
סיף עוד שאני ראיתי מהצד היית המגד הכי
ותיק ו
תשמע אני כאילו מסתכל על בוא נראה איך אתה
לא שפוק ברמה
השם יעזור כאילו החזקת עד הסוף
כן
בפול גאס
כן כן
לאיפה זה האחרים אחי היו באסקי כולם
כן כן אז קודם כל צריך להגיד
המושג הזה של שחיקה ב בתפקיד שלי כמקד הוא
מסכן חיי אדם הוא יכול לסכן סקן חיי אדם
בסוף אני המגד עד הדקה האחרונה של התפקיד
ואנחנו בבנצ'פל ואנחנו בקרב שכל יום יכול
להתפתח ולהיות איזה
אירוע קיצוני אתה צריך להיות חד וממוקד
ולהיות עם האנשים ו100%
מושקע במה שאתה עושה ואני חושב שהאחריות
הזאת זה מה שישב עליי עד הרגע האחרון זה
לא משחק ולא איזה זה העמדת פנים. הייתי שם
במלא
בתפקיד עד הרגע האחרון. למה? כי זה חיי
אדם וזו האחריות שלנו.
יפה מאוד. עוד משהו שאתה רוצה להוסיף שלא
נאמר?
עבודה יפה. לאוריה כמו תמיד. תודה רבה.
תשמע, זה היה חשוב.
כסתי עליך. לא סתם
ממש. תודה רבה.
כמובן יראה לך את הפרקים כל פעם להראות
וזה.
מדהים אחי, מדהים.
תודה רבה אחי.
תודה